the tangible difference in his in his
Vibe is hilarious I know right he used
to be so genuine he had no idea why like
people like them and now it's like three
months ago he just you
know stinky ass bedroom yeah like know
is yeah you know the rules big up to
chips I the know outside out you know
the rules yeah it's silly I big up chip
shop big up big up Dad thanks Dad for
cooking for me
Dad yeah now big up the personal
yeah big
switch oh [__] you think he walks around
the house now just barking at people man
hit that [__] up manate I've got to make
Tik Tok I'm [__] bivo you know who it
is is it I'm Miss to take your [__]
yeah Dad it's also [__] awesome to be
reviewing food you can't have like
reviewing food from your dad that cooked
it uh it's so fun it's so much funnier
than like reviewing food from a
restaurant where you could go and also
have that food yeah like he's just like
my dad's good at cooking but like we'll
never taste that we don't know the
recipe we don't know any we don't know
what it is oh big up the pineapple does
pineapple belong on pizzas let me know
down below oh [__] oh
[__] now mark my words man give it like
a couple months he's going to start
getting political oh yeah I'm telling
you man yeah maybe that right there
that's the beginnings yeah give it two
months yeah he's like I actually [__]
with brexit
and he's going to be a few years behind
cuz the UK is always behind in Trends so
he's going to be there like you know
these blue hair girls yeah they keep
telling me like what I should be
thinking and yeah I'm not going to put
he him in my buer I'm bivo I mean they
all right though I my pronounce to BVO
yeah sorry you're
good you got got some boogers yeah I'm a
little sick I think I just have like a
gnarly fever
kiding it always works it always [__]
works yeah I got some some boogs yeah
he's going to get political man give it
two months it's going to happen that
little commentary right
there and and also man the the [__] boy
ism is
just it's undeniably hilarious do
pineapples belong on
Pizza let me know in the comments let me
know in the comments I think they make
my Sean High good wait did we comment on
that yeah we remember doing
that yeah
damn damn Lauren how did you
know making us look thirsty out
here yeah the two exclamation marks is a
little much God it's looking like hoes
and a self-like oh my God
damn B big up bivo big up big up bivo
holy [__] big
up need a bivo segment oh you got
one damn bro this is the ideal chav
build I'm yeah I'm happy that I could
catch you up on the lore you think this
dude is popping into the clubs in like
Manchester and
[__] yeah I mean if ladies and gentlemen
we've got a massive guest in the
building tonight it's bivo l cover your
tits you're going to swallow the whole
thing he doesn't chew he's the right one
to go down on you it's the one and only
beo and he gets up there
yeah bunch of Asian girls putting orange
chicken on their
chest he's making a rain orange
chicken big up big up girls catching it
not and not chewing you say that he's
going to not chew their tits yeah cover
your tits cuz he's he'll swallow the
whole thing swallow the tits yeah
maximum pleasure one gulp yeah fit your
whole breast in his
mouth you know [__] yeah just maximum
moisture love the way bivo swallows me
tits yeah maximum pressure and uh
moisture on the
areola consistent never a cold spot yeah
yeah you know men use their tongue it's
like the sweeping the floor you know
there's always going to be a cold
portion yeah yeah but this fool will
just
fuckingo teeth out yeah she see the top
of your you look
down he's like It's
banging he's got both of them in there
in the center of your chz he's got both
other sounds like a meat Canyon cartoon
we got to get me Canyon to [__] draw
this oh Hunter loves that Hunter loves
you tell him something to
draw Hunter loves when you tell him
something to draw draw it Hunter yeah
yeah he he loves when people are like
you know you should make a cartoon about
that he loves that does he I'll hit him
up after this then I'll give him a call
both do get group chat oh yeah that's
what we do we have this idea yeah yeah
have a hilarious idea dude this one will
go viral for sure this one's viral this
one
viral oh and also bivo give it like you
know everyone's on his head you know the
fame's gotten to you give it two weeks
and it's going to start to you know the
counter narrative is going to pop up
yeah yo why is bivo kind
of oh yo why he kind of it's start I see
yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz everything's all
aesthetic yeah and liking bivo is going
to be an aesthetic yeah yeah yeah I I
think he's quite attractive I think
people do like him I mean yeah he's got
Charisma undeniably oh yeah for sure I
think I think that's what it is is nerds
were like this is our guy he's like us
and they didn't know nah bivo is the
throat
cat now they're realizing nah man bivo
is um he's not one of the dorks yeah
he's he's one of the boys yeah he's
waiting for his moment don't need to
chew your
foodo we need to [__] make that a
poster
you don't need we need to put it in
Children's Schools yeah yeah you don't
need to chew your
food think critically people you don't
need to chew your food they just tell
you you have
[Laughter]
to that's the problem with the UK they
always want to tell you what to do when
you can use your phone when you can't
how you think how you speak nah stop
chewing stand up to the man don't chew
your
food got these old guys in pubs no he's
[__] right
yeah I don't chew me food
[Laughter]
anymore I'm not going to chew my food
I'm not going to chew my food
anymore just in a in front of a bowl of
soup you weren't Che in
anyways little soup joke yeah drink just
putting a straw in a [__] shepherd's
pie
yeah
crust included banging banging sping
Spang that's that's next that'll be a
music video song titled that's banging
oh you're definitely right dude yeah UK
drill 1,00% and then you know the rules
I said that's banging next and then big
up will be next
yeah kiss me
hanging yeah write it for him yeah right
now okay that's that's it that's all I
has to say that's it yeah what was it
that's banging I'm your big naturals are
hanging yeah big naturals
[Laughter]
hanging uh my me Swinging yeah go to
chip shop my me
Swinging for the chips
yeah I'm hard I like chips in my
mouth they think I'm a something you
know but then he'll talk about how's
from the south and yeah okay some other
[__] yeah even though South is like nice
and PR
yeah then you'll get the Dave
[Laughter]
feature